the amount or the share of generation
who is proud
to be American is
falling off a cliff it's actually insane
and it's something that I actually feel
very deeply about if you look here the
net shares of each generation who say
they are proud to live the United States
wow baby boomers who are essentially our
parents you know in their 60s 70s 73 are
proud to live in the United States Gen X
who are in their 40s and 50s 54 and then
it reaches the below the 50 because all
the news talks about it that's like
depressing and like the police are
killing everybody uh we gotta defund the
police all they talk about is [__] that
makes us want to hate the country it's
crazy yeah it's it well they're they're
victims so nothing can be good these
people I guarantee no matter what you
ask them they're gonna have a negative
view of it anything so why not throw
patriotism into the into the negativity
it's crazy man a threshold when you get
to Millennials 36 and gen Z
16 you're talking teenagers and 20
something year olds who are abundantly
not proud to live in the United States
and as you're saying these stories about
all right economic freedom check okay
say whatever you want for the most part
check I'm wondering where did this shame
come from based on your findings why
people and young people in America are
not proud to be American this is some of
the deeply deeply bothers me
so once again I think there are probably
a lot of causes at play
um so I want to talk about one or two of
them but before I do that just just get
let's get the numbers right so right now
native born American women have about
1.7 children per woman per Lifetime and
again you need two points 2.1 to replace
yourself okay so so it's mostly
immigration which is still driving
um uh our uh our population forward so
America is still growing in terms of
um in terms of its population we are not
talking about the Japanese for example
but it's mostly driven by non-native
American women who are having more
children than immigrants interesting so
it's not even like the main American
women that are repopulating it's the
other it's it's the immigrants I guess
because they're still on more normal
values and they understand that that's
how you like you know keep population
moving by putting more people about
family and they love children yeah
freaks right immigrants now
um possibly I I think
one of the reasons irony though is that
and the Beautiful irony is that the
people who are dissatisfied with this
country they are for open borders and
they're break they're they're just
wanting to flood the country with people
who have values that they hate isn't
that funny they have they're flooding
the country with people who want to
populate oh yeah the people that come
babies people that believe in God people
that love America don't support that
trans [__] I'd like to pull up the stats
if we can um but my understanding is
that immigrants have a very overall
favorable view of speaking about Mike
bro look at it I am look she goes like
this the Mike's down here and she's
looking this way hello why am I not is
this better
yeah that's better I'm always in trouble
oh
awesome what was your point that it's
ironic that they're they're they want to
flood the country with immigrants but
the immigrants have values that are the
absolute antithesis of the values
they're trying to push forward really
and it's kind of it's kind of fantastic
like bring it it is such an
antitheticism so right
in my mind is that I do meet a lot of
young people
and uh part of the reason why they feel
so bad about America is because they're
actually deeply ignorant about the rest
of the world there is very little
understanding from Beyond about just how
rich Americans are vis-a-vis the rest of
the world now I I understand that income
is not the only thing which matters uh
but still in spite of all of our
problems 9 11 financial crisis uh covet
Etc
um we are the richest generation in the
whole history if you ever leave the
country you can if you're on minimum
wage here you can leave the country
basically anywhere and live like a king
in Europe it's so cheap in Mexico if
you're not going to like the tourist
places it's so cheap everywhere else is
there cheap like our money is worth
Western Europe Western Europe it's still
it's still way cheaper than here is it
well okay yeah about it even like
Amsterdam and stuff like it's all
cheaper and that's like the the those
are like the other big places
United States we are much richer than
our ancestors were and not just that
Americans are much richer relative to
the second most developed part of the
world which is Western Europe
um even middle-income America I mean if
if
um
if the Western European income
if you compare it to the American states
to the 50 states it would be on par with
Louisiana and Mississippi the poorest
states in the union those are the
average income how do you calculate that
what's the what's your what formula did
they use to define up
I think this would be this would be GDP
per capita okay and as far as I recall I
mean I saw it online a number of times
from reputable sources I think one of
them was Timber which is a Swedish
Swedish Think Tank
um and and
um the reality is that here in the
United States Mississippi and Louisiana
are the poorest states in the Union
uh and if you go to the richest they are
roughly twice as rich as the poorest
states in the union California New York
California and Western Europe is on the
level of America's poorer State yeah
even Western Europe yes so let's go back
wow so what causes
but you keep having kids why do you why
do you think people what other reasons
do you think people just like
continuously hate the country for
because when you were growing up was it
more patriotic stuff on the news or was
there was there some [__] like this
where they're always [__] on the
country there was a there we learned
about
uh you know Vietnam war protest but but
wasn't that long after so there was
still you know that was still like in
the in the near rear view and there was
a lot of conversation about that people
were pissed that that happened yeah yeah
there were still people mad that the war
happened people were mad at the way they
were treating the veterans when they
came home from the war and there was a
lot of tension in the country but there
was a still not a lack of patriotism so
there were people that really loved the
country there were people that were mad
at the country but didn't hate the
country didn't hate it and that's two
different things and these people that
you know they hate the country and
they're crapping all over it like they
don't even realize it's like hating your
own family the country is you know we
are a family our local community is an
extended family in our nation you know
we're brothers and sisters As Americans
and so if you have a problem you know
but it's true and if we have a problem
with the country we're we should be
trying to solve the problem but not
losing love and respect in that Pro in
that process yeah and to turn around and
say I hate this country and I can't
stand the way every everybody is and the
system and it's all here to Hold Us Down
without looking at any of the positives
and with it is totally unproductive
first of all it just floods everything
with division and negativity and so if
you hate it that much and you're just
going to continue to hate on it you just
need to go it's like your family like
you hate living in this house it's
terrible you you know the food sucks the
people suck the the sofa smells move out
go on your own go somewhere else yeah
like America isn't perfect but it's like
where else do you really go like yeah
you can like Dubai and it's there are
good places to go go go you know if
you're if you're going to be America
self-centered and your whole life is
going to be about me and my feelings it
doesn't matter where they go They're
gonna be miserable right yeah so go be
miserable somewhere else and spare the
rest of us because this is just you're
just a drag these people that I hate
this country you are a drag if you think
there's something broken here fix it but
don't hate in the meantime because it's
unproductive and you're not solving
anything no yeah but like I'm my point
was just like where else do you go like
Mexico sucks it's dangerous Canada sucks
they locked people's bank accounts down
for supporting truckers like how could
you ever want to live there that's
actually but though the general
population
you're really nice in Canada Canadians
are
a rule even if the government is Canada
Western Europe it's all just like I
don't know maybe you moved to Italy I'll
just move to Sicily or something I don't
know about the politics there I don't
know if we have the same freedoms there
I mean look at what we're learning about
the Romanian Criminal Justice System
where they're holding the Tates while
they're doing an investigation it's
crazy that's crazy like I'm not going
anywhere for the record I love America
and I'm staying right here and I am not
turning my back on this country and I
will fight alongside the other people
who love this country to keep our values
and to keep our our rights in place yeah
but these people that hate it they're
going to be miserable no matter where
they go that's why I'm saying like no
matter where it is go away if you're
going to be miserable go to an island go
start your own country in the middle of
the Pacific who cares just go just stop
having kids so aside from a law mandated
by the government like China let's set
that aside that's a law we can't do
nothing about a law right this is
depressing to look at this it's very
disappointing
to see how gen Z feels about
their what do you call it how patriotic
they are but I'm not surprised gen Z
spends the most time with uh teachers
and by the way you meditate the craziest
data about teachers I'll tell you the
craziest data about teachers here we
just got the statistic this last week
based on the research we were doing with
Kai
um do you know what percent and this is
they got this data exactly on how people
gave money contributed
what percentage of Hollywood do you
think votes them to go
it's exactly 90 10. what percentage of
professors
in universities are Democrat to
Republican 97 97 what would you say I
thought it would be a little more than
that like 15 conservative let's see 90
Democrats I would say more than every
one conservative how many Democrats are
there 13 12. it's 1 to 12. it used to be
it's 1 to 12 1 to 13. that's crazy
exactly so 1-12 is uh uh that's a four
does that show that the school system
educates you and shows you the right way
or it just indoctrates indoctrinates you
you know what I'm saying it's a loose
conclusion to make but yeah it's a re
it's a reasonable Theory to investigate
that these these results of these kids
being unpatriotic being taught by people
who do nothing but crap out in the
country yeah it makes sense the wages it
surprise
studies Gen X is my generation and it
surprises me that only what it was 52 or
54 consider themselves to be proud to be
an American a lot of goofballs your age
man hola Monopoly all these people are
worried about monop there's no bigger
Monopoly than this one yeah but watch
this one here so when you think about
gen Z who do they spend the most time
with English teachers what percentage of
English teachers are Democrats oh that's
not that's a hundred percent that's
literally a hundred percent no
conservative is going to be an English
teacher I'm gonna say 100 I'm gonna be
teachers in K-12 99.5 97 please what
percentage of Health teachers are
Democrats the three percent the three
percent are just registered Republicans
they're not even they're not they're
definitely all liberal I've I've never
heard I have some conservative some some
Elementary School teacher friends who
are conservatives
um so rare it's so rare yeah right but
they do exist and they are real it's not
just oh yeah I'm exaggerating but you
know and they all have to stay quiet so
that they don't lose their jobs yeah it
is not something teachers are Democrats
Health teachers in school health and
guidance I'm gonna say 95. 99 go to
Heights English teachers are 97 health
is 99 Health really little one that they
have a little bit of Reason science and
math what percentage are Democrats
remember this requires Logistics
87 to 13 okay so 97 is uh English 99 is
Health uh 87 is Math and Science and gen
z's are spending I don't remember ever
having one conservative teacher at any
of my schools well maybe not publicly
but I'm sure some of them secretly might
have been but for the most part they're
all super super liberal I remember I'm
also educated in Massachusetts where
your your chances of getting real
conservative education are no I remember
my English teacher was once talking and
he was talking about gender and he's
like well we now know gender and you
know sexuality and you know what you you
know what you call yourself it's all a
little bit different and you know boys
can be girls and I literally started
like chuckling he was like what's so
funny Sonny I was like oh nothing Mr
English I'm not gonna say his name but I
remember laughing at that in like 10th
grade I was like this is [__] stupid
I just can't believe ridiculous this is
what a Godless country looks like stop
hints you're going to be thinking like
they do so I am not surprised at all
they're being convinced that America
sucks and America's bad and America is
this and uh get a little one of the
benefits about having YouTube and access
to different channels where you can kind
of brainwash yourself out of the
insanity stuff you've learned you almost
need to unlearn the crap that it's not
even that you're you're you're getting
um that you choose to brainwash yourself
with what you watch it's it's like the
algorithm feeds you what you want so if
you're a little bit to the left it just
drives you down and down and down look
what this conservative did look what
this conservative did all this
propaganda and it's the same with the
people on the far right that just watch
[__] [__] on the left you know
oh yeah it goes both ways oh absolutely
everybody's guilty of it this isn't just
a conservative versus yeah like we watch
we watch a lot of this like transgender
stuff and all this and yeah it's dumb
but it's not like it's like it's not
like a real it's not like a big problem
playing in the country at the end of the
day like trans women in sports like
that's so rare I mean unless I'm missing
something like it's crazy to see but
it's like it is rare in in major liberal
cities they're it's getting more common
the numbers of trans kids mostly girls
have gone through the roof where they're
not happening in other parts of the
country so they can say it's because
they're afraid in those other parts of
the country no it's because every time a
girl has a problem there be she's not
doesn't feel good about herself they're
convincing her that she may actually be
a boy
is that crazy and the teachers are
acting like psychiatrists and no one's
trying to help the child get through the
absolutely natural pain anxiety and
stress of being a teenager and instead
they're just trying to they're they're
cutting telling them to cut off their
body parts and thwart their growth while
their brain isn't even and developed so
I forget your point that I was
addressing already sorry you can
confused I I I'm just so disappointed
in what's happening to to our youth oh
your point was it's not really a problem
so yes it is a problem and what's
happening is their suicide rates are are
still continuing to climb higher than
they've ever been among teenagers and
after transition a suicidal child is
more likely to commit suicide post
transition so what are they solving yeah
all they're doing is creating this
larger population of even more screwed
up people instead of solving the problem
and helping them with their mental
health well they hit you with the logic
that it's not obviously their fault for
killing themselves and it's everyone
else's and that's why we need to be so
accepting and and put this [__]
everywhere then those people will kill
themselves with us and it's like well is
that actually the cause of why they're
killing themselves or is it just because
you know they go to [__] screw loose
right they're in communities especially
in these in schools in you know places
like Los Angeles San Francisco New York
where they're being told that they're
Heroes for coming out so if you're being
told you're a hero every day and you're
strong and you're brave and then you
still offer yourself I know you look at
yourself
your ass kissed I don't even want to
hear it look at this man
look at this man stunning absolutely
stunning you believe the future order
your future looks bright hat if you
believe okay thank you Patrick but David
it was very nice talking to you thank
you guys so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe follow me on Instagram
at sunnyfaz and I'll see you later
[Music]